All right, let's go to, why don't we go, we've
got a lot of interesting phone numbers here.
Let's try going to the three, one seven area
code.
Who's calling today from three one seven.
Yeah.
Hello?
Yes, that's you.
Uh, hi David.
Thanks for taking my call.
I was just wondering if Bernie dropped out
of the race.
Do you think that Elizabeth Warren would have
the presidency for the democratic nomination
on lockdown?
You know, the, the math of it is not that
clear because, um, the, when you look at the
second choice, the second choices for the
supporters of the different candidates, it's
not that obvious that that's the way it would
go.
Let me see if I up the morning consult 20,
20, um, state of the democratic party.
If you said if Bernie dropped out, would it
go to Warren?
Right?
Yeah.
Well, the number one choice for Sam, the number
two choice for Sanders supporters is actually
Biden over Warren.
So, but it's almost 50, 50.
So it seems if Bernie dropped out that Biden
and Warren would basically share her support.
So the math of it is not super clear to me.
All right, cool.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Okay.
Very good.
Uh, you can look that up on morning consult
in case you're a curious.
All right, let's go to Brody from Dallas.
We love Brody from Dallas.
He always has something interesting from for
me.
We haven't heard from him, uh, for a little
over two months.
Brody, what's going on, my friend.
Oh man, I've just been super busy.
How you doing, man?
Good.
All right.
So I actually wanted to dive into something,
um, that, uh, I've noticed that hasn't been
touched on the debates and I wanted to get
your perspective on it.
Uh, being the brilliant economist.
Um, and it's that we've seen, we've seen a
lot of, uh, and, and rightly so.
We've seen a lot of focus on college and postsecondary
education, student loans, tuition and debt
and how that obviously has an effect on our
economy and a variety of different and great
proposals by many candidates.
And we've just heard some mentioned that had
started pre-K. I wanted to know what you thought
about is if we're not diving in a deep enough
into the focus on essentially reforming our
funding formula for schools because as you
know, most areas get it from property taxes,
which contributes to inequality.
Yup.
Lots of bad things.
What are some, um, suggestions that you might
have come across, uh, or any kind of progressive
ideas that, um, you might promote or look
a suggest people look into in terms of their
own communities for better funding formula?
And what are some opportunities there?
I mean, listen, it needs to be done systemically
unless there's, you know, you're not going
to do it with bake sales and fundraisers I
think is the idea.
So at a certain point it needs to be, are
we just going to be funding education through
property taxes?
And often it's not just property taxes, it's
a combination of state funds distributed often
on a per population basis combined with property
taxes.
Are we just going to do that or are we going
to do some kind of what might be called like
a special assessment or an override of some
kind.
And at the city and town level, when I was
growing up in North Hampton, Massachusetts,
there were often initiatives, ballot initiatives
about do we want to do another half point
on property taxes over the next however long.
Uh, but the, the more novel approach would
be instead of doing it as an addition to property
tax, look at some version of what Elizabeth
Warren or Bernie Sanders are talking about
in terms of a wealth tax.
Now, I know in the past I've said, legally,
this may be complicated and I'm not backing
up on that.
I'm just saying it's an idea.
Look at using some kind of rat rather than
tacking it onto property tax where it will
affect middle-class homeowners that can't
really afford to pay more, uh, look at doing
some kind of a very, very high net worth either
wealth tax or income tax or something like
that.
And um, you know, the political viability
of it is a question Mark obviously, but it's
gotta be more you, it's not going to be able
to be bake sales and fundraisers,
right?
It's got to be centralized and yeah, you're
right.
We could, we actually have existing things
like title one that we could also implement
those funds too.
And um, did you have any specific thoughts
on, um, in terms of like, we look at that,
the Devoss and your advocacy in charter schools
and you've made a really good point that the
money follows the students.
Do you think that a, a central funding formula,
uh, from the, uh, national government or a
larger organization would help eliminate some
of the problems that we see with charter schools?
It's possible, but that is going to create
an S storm of, um, States rightists saying,
Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, hold on a second.
That's not the way you can do it.
So I, I mean it's, it's certainly possible,
but I don't see it as being successful in
any kind of medium term way.
Right on, man.
I just wanted to get your opinion on that
because we're focusing on college and the
higher education, which is great, but I just
wanted to hear some opinions and, uh, talk
about a local funding formula.
Very good.
Brody, I'm hearing an accent today that I
haven't noticed from you before.
Are you from like Pennsylvania, New Jersey,
some, somewhere in there?
I'm actually from California.
Oh, California.
Interesting.
Really bad.
Yeah.
I've got really bad congestion today from
the terrible allergies here.
Gotcha.
Okay.
That might've been it.
All right, Brody.
Very good.
Good to hear from you.
[inaudible] ADP.
Okay.
Take it easy.
We'll take a quick break.
Don't hang up if you're holding because we
will go right back through the phones just
after this short friends